I'm Michael K I'm Morgan Freeman I seem
to be an anarchic we're doing the wired
autocomplete interviews you're making it
more difficult than it needs to be I
think your first one is that much is
Morgan Freeman a ballet dancer no Morgan
Freeman is not a ballet dancer is Morgan
Freeman a big keeper in a manner of
speaking I am I have a lady of Gardner
who is the actual beekeeper they're my
bees but she keeps them happy and
healthy
I'm very much built up yeah we did what
is Morgan Freeman like in real life well
it's a bit of a pain in the Bible if you
ask me we can vouch for them yeah we
back him up on that one I don't lie
what movies is Morgan Freeman God aid
that God good God
I played God in Bruce Almighty and a
little bit in real life as well
is this my on the same thing is this in
my turn or not okay what headboard a
frame was done for society very little
does Alan Arkin yes he does does he
yes all right does Alan Arkin speak
rushing yeah I know I don't speak
Russian by stood I can still remember
the lines from the Russians are coming
Slavko a Capitan story story jlidgett
just out so reckon it's very kind of
worked for three months everybody you
got the pot does Alan Arkin live yes how
I reckon so forth those did not say that
it says where we oh I live half the year
in Canada and half the years Neil
instance see me later I'll tell you
exactly no don't you do what your rights
ever speak tivity kevin pollak does alan
arkin yeah he does a mean version of it
to the extent where he's left messages
on my answering machine as me and i
thought it was me hey this allegation
that Rainey who was a little
was I in our car have you ever do so
well yeah yeah I was a producer Lord oh
yeah it's me now does Michael Caine oh
whoa I did does Michael Caine have a son
no I don't I have two daughters but I
was very lucky I've got a grandson and
he looks just like me
only it's better looking does my cocaine
have a gold tooth lower couldn't afford
it I've got a metal one it tastes better
than gold metal it's more masculine does
my I own the leggings yeah I under to
language what's whittling wood Langan
soon I was doing a picture with a Sidney
Poitier and he said you're always on
about opening a load like a pole in
Paris he said the chef where I go he's
always on about it and it was a guy
called Peter lang it the restaurant was
a massive success but but Peter ended he
killed himself
China murder his wife that boy well I
asked a simple question well you know
language it was a great big Brasserie
okay so you what here the menu Oh Paul
this thing I'm holding it
okay next one that's Michael Caine doing
pressure yeah I do great impression of
me my name is Michael Caine you're
selling yourself short all the time yeah
his name is Sir my chubby buddies I
would never let that go
no matter of fact I want to change my
citizenship to English so I can become
so it would be a sir instantly how did
we make the kind of secure meat it was
in the days of disco and everything in
out getting bombed and staying out till
two o'clock in the morning my best
friend and I we were tired and we
decided to stay in one night and do
something we've never done which was
watched television there was a
commercial for Maxwell House came on and
there was his fitting from Brazil like
to a copy beans and there was this
beautiful girl telling you is it got a
lot of coffee and presented all that she
was extraordinary and I feel a don't my
a minute Mary girl I said my friend will
go to Brazil in the morning and find her
and I went down to discotheque no we
hadn't gone to that night the man came
in he said what are you doing is the
three of you know girls I said I fell in
love with a girl on the
tonight in a commercial I said Maxwell
House he said we make that commercial he
said she's not in Brazil she lives in
the Fulham Road in London so I phoned
her the next day and she wouldn't go out
with me hmm
and I found it for ten days since she
would go out with me but on the last day
she did and we've never left each other
since hmm let's hope my wife
look he's asleep already being sleeps a
lot do you know of what old people are
like oh this is different oh good frame
a gun moving does Morgan Freeman have
boots
no I do yes really well they got blue
rings around them oh I got red ones does
Morgan Freeman have a tattoo yes I do
have a tattoo I was in love with a girl
and I had I was going to put her
initials on my arm inside this heart and
when they put the tattoo on either side
of wait a minute this is going to be
here the rest of my life yeah does
Morgan Freeman like from Morgan Freeman
does his own stunts if it had anything
to do with a woman yes how does Morgan
Freeman get his freckles how does let
you pee that I used every morning - uh
typical doc come on get your ID what is
alan arkin
beetle mmm what is all american famous
for falling asleep alan arkin is famous
for quite a few very very good
portrayals and you some very good movies
thanks for finding a word I could name
some for you but with them bleed really
be here all day what a sell in Arkansas
I used to be 510 1/2 and now 5 minute
everybody thinks I'm a for some
reason what nationality's on earth I'm
American you're not American I swear you
are born American was born and learn and
when I parents were born in ask anybody
sit a Lamarck and even the name will
tell you you put somewhere else what is
a Larkins auspice speech English my
speech was English what is alan arkin
twitter I have I have no Twitter I don't
own a social media life is too short
alright so much for that that's it you
later right now now wait a minute wait
well I'm not gonna do this unless you
give short answers ok give a sure all
right
when did my cocaine start acting I
started acting in
in school when I was 10 years old
Rex was here wait a minute and I played
bad fits noodle who is the father of the
ugly sisters in Cinderella and I got a
laugh because my flies were undone and I
took up acting based on the laughs when
did Michael Caine forget his lines I've
never forgotten me lines
you were never forgotten oh I have a
memory like a computer what happened is
I should I was going to read the
question I don't Wendy my train say my
name is I never said it was invented by
Peter Sellers when did Michael Caine
died I haven't been to a few yes but
I've died in several reviews and a quite
a few pictures but I remember India
Michael Payne ever pay the equal or a
whistle as a equaliser the equalizer
whistles guy who goes and takes care of
people's problems a gangster power and
stuff I sort of might get Carter Oh
inequal oh yeah I played an equalizer
get corner you're very a very very very
tough gangster but I've never I've never
killed anybody my foot okay you're never
expecting them to run on like that did
you
what's happening be out of here